oggi parliamo appunto di un tema
affascina
le attività in particolare la fertilità
femminile
ovviamente la ventata vinile
innanzitutto un problema di cuore di
affetto ma anche un problema di vita di
organizzazione di lavoro di cultura più
in generale nelle parole che ho usato
adesso ne manca una però importante ed è
quello su cui cercheremo di lavorare
oggi manca la parola biologia cioè al di
là di tutto il contesto in cui si può
sviluppare desideri diventare mamme a
monte di questo cioè come funzionano
vaio la fertilità e quello che succede
sempre più oggi è che il tempo passa e
cercheremo di raccontare la biologia e
come funzionano vaio come se avessimo un
libretto delle istruzioni uno di quelli
dimenticati nel cruscotto della propria
macchina perché è proprio quello che
succede passa il tempo
la macchina un po invecchia la
carrozzeria interni e allora si decide
di metterla in ordine si rifà la
verniciatura si rifanno gli interni e
spesso si dimentica il motore in questo
caso il motore della fertilità ed è
quello di cui appunto parleremo in modo
che quando poi si trovasse la situazione
in cui diventa possibile a diventare
mamme si vuole diventare mamme non si
rimane in panne perché si è messo a
posto la macchina ma ci si è dimenticati
del motore quello che vedete qui è una
serie di colonnine importantissime allo
scopo della nostra chiacchierata voi
vedete che c'è una colonnina verde che
corrisponde a 25 anni e c'è scritto 25
per cento cosa vuol dire vuol dire che a
25 anni nella finestra fertile tra il
xii e il quattordicesimo giorno tra una
mestruazione e l'altra c'è un quarto di
possibilità di poter concepire avendo
rapporti liberi
se andiamo a 35 anni questa possibilità
non è più il 25 per cento cioè una volta
su quattro ma 15 per cento
se scendiamo poi a 40 anni si arriva
quel numerino rossa la colonnina rossa
piccolina che circa il 5 per cento cosa
vuol dire 5 per cento vuol dire che
occorrono mediamente parlando 20 mesi
per avere la probabilità avendo rapporti
per 20 mesi
nella finestra fertile di concepire una
gravidanza 20 mesi sono quasi due anni
ed è sicuramente troppo quindi questo è
la prima informazione che il manuale che
stiamo leggendo che avevamo dimenticato
ci sta dando l'età conta è quindi molto
spesso la coppia la donna pensa che
fertilità e mestruazione regolare siano
la stessa cosa questo grafico ci dice di
no non è così
questo ce lo dice ancora in maniera più
chiara la linea viola che vedete fatto
101 il massimo della partita tra 20 e 30
anni vediamo poi che questa linea scende
a 35 anni e ancor di più a 40 anni
quindi questo è un dato medio è
naturalmente ci sarà chi è più fortunata
e quindi questa riga si sposta un po più
in là nel tempo quindi la fertilità
rimane anche un pochino più avanti
specie che invece vede questa linea
spostarsi a sinistra
parliamo parliamo del 5 per cento delle
donne una donna su 20 ha la possibilità
alla sfortuna di vedere questa
possibilità di fertilità ridursi già
intorno ai 30 anni non ai 35 allora
cos'è messaggio che il primo capitolo di
questo manuale ci dice che se a 30 anni
come messo spesso capita oggi siena la
necessità di posticipare la gravidanza
occorrerà fare riferimento a uno
specialista per capire se sia quella
donna fortunata che rimane fertile
tranquillamente fino a 40 anni
oppure quella donna su 20 che invece a
30 anni già deve cominciare a
preoccuparsi del fatto che la propria
fertilità spontanea sta decadendo
assieme alle tappe assieme questa
variabilità della biologia come
funzionano le varie l'età comporta altre
piccole cose che non sono
nulla di importante per la salute della
donna parliamo ad esempio di una parola
che tutti hanno già sentito più volte in
casa delle amiche le nonne le zie i
fibromi o e miomi come si dice no voi
vedete qua lo schema in cui c'è un
disegno un utero in pianta con la carità
triangolare bianca a sinistra ea destra
avesse un disegno un pochino più
complesso vediamo maniera più schematica
con la parte bianca è una cavità
regolare quindi ideale per raccogliere
le voci ta fertilizzato a destra invece
vedete c'è il segno azzurro un mio ma
tre centimetri niente di importante per
la salute della donna ma vedete la
cavità e deformata è un fattore che
riduce alla fertilità quindi quando ci
si trova nella condizione di posticipare
la fertilità alla gravidanza alla
famiglia occorre sapere che non ci sia
nulla di tutto ciò e che quindi si possa
o intervenire oppure serenamente pensare
di andare un pochino più in là questo è
un elenco vedete in rosso e il blu delle
parole strane adenomiosi polipi
endometriali sono parole che fanno
riferimento a piccoli disturbi
dell'utero delle ovaie e ancora una
volta questi non hanno nessun impatto
sulla salute della donna ma possono
avere appunto l'impatto sulla fertilità
in cima a questo elenco vedete a parte
il fumo che proprio una cosa per cui ci
si fa del male volontariamente in testa
ho messo questa parola obesità
all'obesità non è un problema estetico
vedete qua una modella che sfila con un
vestito di un famoso modo famoso futuri
eba la visita può comportare come
vediamo in questo grafico un problema
relativamente al concepimento vedete le
colonnine sono una verde gialla e una
rossa e sotto ci sono dei numeri 25 30
25 vuol dire un peso normale una donna
di 35 anni di peso normale diciamo che
ha una possibilità di concepire del 90
per cento
se la stessa donna la stessa età fosse
obesa vedete la colonnina rossa diventa
piccola
e concede la possibilità di concepire si
riduce quindi l'obesità che purtroppo
sta diventando un problema epidemico in
alcuni paesi anche l'italia sta
veramente incominciando a preoccuparvi
un 30 per cento di bambini obesi in
italia è l'obesità è un problema
strategico di salute sappiamo 50 anni si
diventa diabetici a 60 ipertesi bisogna
fare un sacco di cure ma già a 30 anni
la possibilità di concepire si riduce
nel nostro libretto di istruzioni
troviamo poi una parte che ci spiega le
strade no in cui la fertilità si muove e
come come prendere qui vedete carriera
nuovo lavoro lavoro precario abitazione
perché quello che sta succedendo oggi
abbiamo a milano l'età media della prima
gravidanza ai 36 anni soltanto 40 anni
fa era 25 anni questo sicuramente non è
dovuto al fatto che le coppie le donne
non vogliono avere bambini in generale
ma è legato proprio al modo in cui la
società organizzata in cui la donna che
entra nel mondo del lavoro si trova a
vivere e molto spesso molto spesso la
gravidanza al essere mamme nel letto
come un tradimento della mission
aziendale non si arriva al mobbing ma
molto frequentemente questo è più tempo
in un handicap di carriera ricordo un
anno fa circa facciamo in mangiagalli
dove lavoro una riunione con molte
aziende importanti milanesi fumo
sorpresi dal fatto che una sola azienda
aveva considerato nel curriculum delle
candidate nel curriculum delle persone
da assumere la maternità equivalente un
master di pubbliche relazioni
allora incuriositi che abbiamo questo
direttore del personale come mai
e questo in sé ma insomma se per gestire
il cambiamento nella famiglia al
cambiamento nel rapporto coi partner e
gestire un esserino che neanche parla
sicuramente questa donna sarà più capace
di gestire il cliente arrabbiato
piuttosto che una situazione di riunione
complessa quindi era un titolo di
carriere
purtroppo quindi la mappa in cui che la
fertilità biologica si muove oggi per la
donna è una mappa complessa e bisogna
tenerne conto e quindi bisogna tenere
conto di quanto abbiamo detto sin qua
quindi estrazione regolare non è uguale
fertilità uguale c'è l'età e con l'età
ci sono possono essere piccoli problemi
o grandi problemi che devono essere
conosciuti ed eventualmente risolti
voglio chiudere con un messaggio di
positività non è perché faccio vedere
due belle signore vi chiedete perché
questo punto facciamo vedere due belle
signore una famosissima e l'altra forse
anche sicuramente meno e ci chiediamo il
senso di queste immagini senso è che
sono due signore vissuta in condizioni
300 400 anni prima una e l'altra
condizioni di vita completamente diverse
culturali diverse che cosa hanno in
comune queste due signore l'ovulazione
400 anni fa e oggi è rimasto uguale come
rimasto uguale sistema cardiovascolare i
polmoni come si forma l'energia e quindi
quello che noi ci chiediamo oggi è che
cosa possiamo fare visto che la mappa in
cui il nostro la nostra macchina si
muove in cui dobbiamo usare le
istruzioni che conosciamo
e così complessa e così difficile
potremmo quasi dire che la nostra non è
una società per mamme
allora vediamo cosa possiamo fare
qualcosa sicuramente sì innanzitutto
parliamo di stile di vita
noi siamo fatti per camminare e muoversi
correre scappare dagli animali selvatici
raccogliere per chilometri e chilometri
barche ma che rossi per poter mangiare e
oggi siamo seduti alla scrivania otto
ore capita di vedere la mangiagalli e su
due piani cave di qualcuno che prende
l'ascensore per salire al piano sopra e
neanche le scale
ok questo non va bene perché vuol dire
che il nostro sistema cardiovascolare
sì sì ecco è come un motore senza olio
motore che funziona male quindi
l'attività fisica qualunque essa sia
va assolutamente perseguito quando vedo
i signori che vanno in giro per milano
le cose elettrici che neanche li fanno
camminare veramente
spero che questo non lo facciano nel
signore che vogliono mantenere una buona
fertilità parte vuoto pilates yoga corsa
capello che volete
basta che il vostro cuore i colori di là
dei segnali di fertilità al vostro
organismo e quindi alle varie
la seconda parte che oggi possiamo
giocare contro il tempo per mantenere la
qualità della fertilità è
l'alimentazione l'alimentazione la parte
principale di quello che noi medici in
termini complicati chiamiamo e sposò ma
cioè tutte le cose che influiscono sulla
nostra salute l'alimentazione è la parte
più importante l'intestino sono 360
metri quadrati quindi è la parte più
esposta all ambiente esterno quello che
ci mettiamo dentro condiziona la salute
perché ogni giorno e pensiamo di essere
gli stessi ma ogni giorno noi
distruggiamo e facciamo trilioni di
cellule non mille non 100.000 non un
miliardo miliardi di miliardi di cellule
ogni giorno si rifanno e come li
facciamo ti facciamo quei mattoncini dei
cibi che mangiamo e che vanno a fare le
nuove cellule
quindi se mangiamo un olio polinsaturo o
mangiamo lo zucchero piuttosto che
mangiamo del pesce che mangiamo della
verdura i mattoncini che ne diamo nostro
organismo sono diversi del nostro
organismo nell'organismo della donna una
parte delicatissima e l'ovaio questa
cosa grossa che vedete in realtà sono
tre centimetri ci sono dentro quando
nasciamo la scelta e 300mila ovociti
ciascuno dei quali viene richiamato alla
vita una volta al mese da cellule
delicatissime un sistema molto
particolare di cui non siamo qui a
parlare ma concettualmente è uno dei
meccanismi più delicati e più
energeticamente dispendiosi
dell'organismo
allora come vi arriva il sangue quanto
assisano di arriva prima attività fisica
e chi mattoncini che si danno per far
funzionare questo meccanismo sono
fondamentali quindi se vogliamo
percorrere queste strade complicate di
una società non per mamme
e mantenere una certi lita l'attività
fisica e l'alimentazione sono importanti
una volta di colore su alimentazione
leggevo su next qualche mese fa un
articolo straordinario hanno trovato un
campo di battaglia del 1700 qualcosa tra
inglesi e scozzesi che si picchiavano
sempre che adesso si picchiano tra di
loro
40.000 morti scheletri prima vedono a
vedere come sono morti lasciate a
bardate eccetera poi ho un dentista
venuto in mente di andare a vedere i
denti di questi morti tra i 20 ei 40
anni
noi quanto vediamo il pirata dei caraibi
vediamo questi due uomini con i tuoi
denti neri che di cari eccetera bene non
c'era una carie nei denti di questi
campioni di 40.000 signora di morte nel
1600 perché non c'era lo zucchero lo
zucchero non è un alimento umana è stato
introdotto in alimentazione nel 1750
quando hanno dei caraibi è cominciata la
pa e poi francesino scoperta di
barbabietole da zucchero lo zucchero non
è un alimento umana zucchero fa male
l'organismo in generale quindi meno le
mangiate meglio è dolci solo alla
domenica come facevano le bisnonne ed
evitiamo di danneggiare questi
meccanismi delicatissimi di cui abbiamo
parlato finora tante note tecniche previ
penso di essere riuscito a dare qualche
informazione utile con questo cruscotto
altrimenti che molte donne dimenticano
che pensano capita qualche volta una
coppia che arriva 38 30 40 anni beh
adesso facciamo ancora qualche anno
assieme poi decideremo di fare un figlio
la biologia non funziona così e non
vorrei parlare però solo di biologia
vorrei chiudere dicendo che tutto questo
discorso
e per che cosa e perché la gravidanza
avere dei figli educarli è un'esperienza
straordinaria per la donna ma era senza
solo in aria anche per noi è un mondo
meraviglioso ed avere un peccato dover
tutte le volte purtroppo spesso oggi
dover intervenire con la medicina dove
intervenire saltare quei passi naturali
che invece sono così belli così
spontanee e spero di avere aiutato
qualcuno a immaginare un modo diverso di
arrivare a questa esperienza
meravigliosa ho finito grazie